pays d'origine qui kert et deux
présidents des conseils départementaux
fanaye diéry pendant les brigitte
klinkert les deux présidents des
conseils départementaux bas rhin et haut
rhin ont remis cet après midi leur
projet d'une collectivité territoriale
d'alsace au préfet marx à saint-servan
bonsoir c'est un rapport que vous avez
lu évidemment un rapport enrichi par les
contributions des citoyens effectivement
david ce rapport d'abord c'est le fruit
d'un travail collectif mené par les deux
présidents des départements les élus
alsaciens et aussi les alsaciens eux
mêmes un site internet expression
citoyenne alsace était à leur
disposition ils étaient treize mille à
s'y exprimer
alors que dit précisément ce rapport
alors stéphane guerry et brigitte
klinkert ribéry
pardon un frédéric bry et brigitte
klinkert propose ici à leur vision de
l'alsace de demain d'abord il accepte
que l'alsace reste dans le grand est
le président macro ne leur a pas
vraiment laissé le choix
ensuite ce projet c'est celui d'une
collectivité d'alsace à statut
particulier
en clair pas de fusion des deux
départements mais une seule collectivité
un peu à l'image de celle que l'on
connaît en corse
je vous propose d'écouter les deux
présidents des départements
nous ce que nous souhaitons aujourd'hui
c'est réunir des compétences des deux
départements et compétences de la région
et des compétences de l'état pour servir
un projet de re collectivités d'alsace
donc l'unité département subsisterait
c'est la collectivité département qui
elle serait amenée à évoluer en rentrant
dans une collectivité d'alsace à statut
particulier l'intérêt
du processus que nous proposons c'est de
maintenir la et la préfecture de colmar
et la préfecture de strasbourg l'intérêt
aussi c'est que en fusionnant nos deux
assemblées départementales je dis bien
deux assemblées départementales cela
nous permet d'avoir une meilleure
capacité à agir demain grâce aux
compétences que nous demandons d'une
part à la région et d'autre part à
l'état justement quelles sont les
compétences alors cette collectivité et
d'alsace aura des compétences élargies
certaines transférées par l'état comme
la gestion des routes nationales par
exemple ou encore le recrutement des
enseignants bilingues
d'autres seraient partagés avec la
région comme la compétence du
développement économique et agricole ou
encore l apprentissage donc le préfet il
a ce rapport entre les mains quelle est
donc la suite du programme
alors le préfet marx doit rendre sa
copie au premier ministre en juin
les porteurs de cette collectivité à
d'alsace un statut unique espère un
retour d'ici l'automne pour une mise en
oeuvre en 2021
merci beaucoup alors le détail
évidemment de ce projet est à retrouver
sur notre site internet france3 grant
est un vote